have you ever licked sweat
you guys call that a knife that's a
knife you're about to wear this [ __ ]
murder here in trash taste
oh [ __ ] lost a thumb there no worries
it's good it's good i just won't use
that again
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to another trash taste special
so we hear a trash taste unknown for our
[ __ ] food taste and we know you guys are
probably tired of that by now so we
thought why not change things let's go
and hire a michelin star chef to go and
teach us how to cook so we were each
taught three different dishes and we not
only have to learn it on the day but we
also have to recreate it as best as we
can
from memory then after we cook it we're
going to be judged masterchef style on
how well we do in our cooking skills
which uh i'm like not feeling confident
at all i hope it's toast
i can't cook but i'm a good learner and
i always give my all
so that's why i swallow matters that's
the heart that matters
that was probably the least confident
fighting was i've ever come out of
connor's mouth
listen i you know i'm a humble man
i know what i'm gonna lose first week of
2022 he's already lying
also there might be some scenes in this
that would be disturbing to some viewers
so we've had to censor the episode
slightly uh because joey committed
murder yes i apologize it wasn't it
wasn't my choice
so if you'd like to see the full
uncensored video and experience me
killing a fish
then go over to our patreon patreon.com
and you'll also be supporting us in
future trash taste episodes and specials
so without further ado here's the trash
taste cooking special enjoy cooking a
skill that can range from simple home
chefs to those that stand at the top of
the culinary world it's an art form that
can take years to perfect so let's see
what three idiots can learn in a day so
we're here at the catherine diner
officer i hope i pronounced that
correctly and we are about to do some
cooking yes great i have had ubereats
for the past like four months straight
i've had ubereats for the past 26 years
of my life so i've just been watching
sydney do a bunch of cooking so i hope i
can absorb sydney's cooking skill via
osmosis today we're going to be learning
how to cook with michelin star chefs
it's a real jump up isn't it we went
from cooking toast to michelin yeah i
mean i know how to cook a was a cheese
grilled sandwich oh i don't know is that
what it's called i get all good one of
those
either way we're going to be an
embarrassment and we're going to see who
is going to be the best chef today you
could say the mastership
i'm [ __ ] correct can we leave that in
is that a branding issue we're not
sponsored by masterchef all right let's
go all right let's see what's the
kitchen's like i don't like kitchens
oh my god look at this place this is
crazy
this is massive i feel like i'm on
hell's kitchen right now is this what
it's like going on like one of those
reality tv shows maybe so these are the
two chefs that will be helping us to
hopefully be a much better chef than we
already are chef koji is a michelin star
chef specializing in traditional
japanese cuisine formerly a chef at
yotro which is now closed down he's
recently opened a new restaurant
hinokincho lab where he hopes to welcome
even more guests from around the world
chef mack is the founder and lead guide
of maktion planet that specializes in
giving authentic japanese experiences
for willing participants like
these three idiots we have something for
you guys actually
okay
oh my god i brought an apron but
i brought an apron but screw that oh
mike's his carrying on it
what says monkey mine says of course
grant oh hell yeah i guess today i'm
chef grant i'm chef karen i guess chef
karen chef grant and chef monkey hello
how you doing how do i put on an apron i
hate to start asking for lessons already
about how do you tie this
initiative test number one yeah
yes i passed the first test oh no if
they can't put the aprons on we'll just
end it now
that's it that's it
it's not just printed on that's like
that's that embroidered stuff right
there
it's all right we get it it's important
it's embroidered i love embroidery just
say one more time joe say one more time
it's embroidered so what is the next
step then what are we doing now i think
the first step
is that we will be teaching you
individually three different dishes
okay we're not going to tell you what
they are
okay the suspense is killing me all you
need to decide is who's going to go
first
well i think i think joe wanted to go
first so what jerry oh you know what
i'll take the ball for the team i'll go
first all right let's do it i was up
first and as someone with almost zero
cooking experience i wasn't feeling too
confident so chef is it an issue
that i have basically zero experience in
the kitchen i don't think i've ever
properly cooked something actually no
that's like i made a uh chicken and gino
verse pasta before but that's really the
only cooking experience i have so you're
a brave guy
thank you yes because you choose your
first one
oh
that's worrying okay so what's your
experience with cooking donna i've
cooked pre-packaged meals
in the oven in order to make a really
good japanese
dishes most important factor is
ingredients ingredients of course yeah
the most important thing is
how fresh it is right right so from now
i'm gonna teach you how to make
sashimi oh okay
okay fish
i purchased
from
toyota market oh the fish market your
fish market prior in the morning toyota
fish market is tokyo's most famous fish
market forget a home cook these are
fresh ingredients a pro chef would dream
of and to top it off chef koji had a big
surprise for me wait is it alive yes oh
my god
yeah the flounder flounder in japanese
we call it
makogade oh wow i don't think i've
actually ever seen
a flounder in real life i'm gonna show
you how to
hey buddy
you're going
to you think jerry's going to be good at
it
i don't think joey's going to be good at
it i reckon jerry could be good you know
jerry's a pretty good learner i think
when it's not cars yeah
in terms of like a kitchen there's a lot
of health and safety hazards there
probably not as much as drifting but
connor's going to find a way to break
something i'm sure
you have to
cut
here okay
whoops like this okay okay all right and
then after that
cut
the tape
okay
oh it's very hard isn't it like this
after that with these
strings
we have to raise
[Music]
jesus christ all right break the nerve
here
okay okay yes so so this is going
through the spine yes i guess okay okay
so now we're running by the main bomb
right and we can
keep it uh fresh longer this uh
technique exists especially in japan
right so that's why we can eat a lot of
fish and sashimi oh because if you kill
it bad then the the meat tenses up right
and it doesn't taste good
shall we move to the sink yeah get rid
of the blood yeah
while joey was learning how to commit
first degree murder chef mac kindly
explains just how hard it is to be a
chef another british person has joined
us we are taking over as we are you know
historically known for oh my god do you
want to explain a bit about your like
background and history i'm mac i've been
living in tokyo for 15 years the
greatest city on earth the world's
greatest metropolis actually as i like
to call it a lot of people they say
think oh new york is the greatest city
on earth right yeah i mean it isn't
terrible what are they saying it's
typically said by people who have only
been to new york by virtue of their
birth and true trash takes fashion not
on cue at all we start the first thing
we do is start [ __ ] talking americans
right i was i have i wasn't even
prompted
he wasn't prompted at all normally uh we
take off the scale with a special
equipment it's like a brush right yes
like a brush okay but this one is so
tiny right so that's why using this
if you take off the
tiny
scale oh it's turning white yeah yeah oh
cool cool okay i'm sorry if you're a
vegan watching this it's probably
clicked off typically how much training
does a chef need to go through well you
know how you hear these things about
these restaurants like
in the sushi restaurants the guy's got
to make the rice for 10 years before
he's even allowed to touch the fish koji
was telling me about like cutting a
daikon
and he had to learn how to cut this
daikon so thin and so perfectly that you
could basically roll it out so that the
thing like looks transparent you know
you can see the veins
in the vegetable and you know this was
like months and months of him like in
the kitchen just having to cut this with
with the senpai you know the the boss
chef going you know again
again and he also has some uh zen
training as well so kind of all of that
has combined to what's the zen training
well so he's trained in a temple you
know like lived in a temple for like god
so to be a chef in japan you literally
need like temple trade for zen training
and also cooking training it's more
wherever you get that mindset from you
know i mean there's a lot of you know
cliched words around it the shocking in
the craftsman but you basically need
that mindset forget going through ten
years of zen training i was already
having trouble keeping up with all the
steps i needed to do i've cut a reel a
little bit okay
oh okay okay there's the intestines yeah
and then
just pull it out yes
okay so we're washing out the blood
right here from the inside so without
spoiling how hard are like the things
that we're going to be doing today i'm
also curious at this pretty tough
pretty
pretty
pretty
tough
the most important thing to keep on
making
good uh good food
i mean good dish you have to
keep every we're free for your
sashimi uh we
use
and this is the one where you kind of
have to like slide like that right okay
this side no knife is on the top of the
ball okay right
so it kind of just goes right across
okay
okay
[Music]
oh wow okay this is very
tough you're doing very well
can you hear this here's a bomb
so
how do you think rims
so we have to take off the
the ribbon
[Music]
hell yeah
nailed it can you hear the difference
from
this part on this part here's a
very thin skin yeah so we have to take
off the
skin here and this is the the big boy
comes in right now
big boy is waiting big boy is waiting
okay i think the bones on this side
is the bone here did i go straight
through the middle
i might have gone yeah i might have gone
straight through the middle of that damn
it yeah oh i hear the sound
let's go that's so satisfying when you
get it so i'm hoping that i don't do
pretty well in this park that'll mean
that it's a curse waiting to happen and
i'll [ __ ] it up at the end so the plot
says connor's gonna win today because i
don't think you want a proper trash
taste special yeah some of the pc
building it's like half a special it's
an independent observer with an official
independent observer white coat on that
was a legit win thank you thank you even
though i messed up a bunch this is the
ultimate test i feel this is what makes
or breaks a very aesthetic
sashimi bowl japanese food culture is
all about how good it looks you got to
feed the eye before you feed the stomach
as they say
so depending on how well i cut this or
how much i [ __ ] up
it's going to depend look at that that
looks clean
damn
yes
let's go oh we're like fully plating up
all right all right
so we got the radishes yes there are
dishes
we feel radish
that's a mountain of radish yes
and the shape
into a bowl
like a like a bowl
here
you are so dedicated person why don't
you come to our
my restaurant to hell yeah i just got a
job offer
have you ever seen the
twisted carrot oh it doesn't come
pre-cut
[ __ ] we cut it with this angle
and put it into the water
whoa okay
oh cool okay look at that when you when
you put it down like that it was very
cute is there any like uh tips for the
actual fight like things i should look
out for you're already great
so cool anyway keep it clean keep it
clean okay as the only japanese person
in trash taste it is my duty i feel to
do and pay respect to
my culture right here sashimi is very
much a japanese culture and i will
hopefully be able to make something that
you will be proud of all right thank you
censor
and finally it was time to taste the
fruits of my labor all right well uh i
figured i'm gonna take a bite of my
first dish or the dish i'll be making to
the judges just to see if i even did a
good job or not
so let me just take that
this thing was alive until an hour ago
that's scary to think about all right
thank you mars
[Music]
that's so good oh my god all right let
me take some of
the radish here you gotta be on japanese
tv oh yeah i'm gonna be on japanese tv
right
japanese tv it's going to be shaky as
possible right get a zoom in on that
shake that's how you that's how you do
japanese quality
umasa
oh hell yeah that's super nice
okay good to know
what i mean tastes good
now i just got to replicate that
again this is going to be hard
we're done thank you
all right all right next person and next
it was my turn up i was going to be
learning a different dish and i've never
seen this fish before in my life wow
that's a lot of knives
i'm going to teach you kind of japanese
really classic fish and chips
i can't escape
it's a dish i'm familiar with but doing
it myself is completely different story
i was like i never knew i was this
uncoordinated
is this red thai fish
tile fish yeah we call it amada this
fish is common in the kyoto in order to
make this
deep fried fish this side will be the
best the other two guys take after
the scale but
for this dish we don't take off the skin
perfect nice okay a little easier a
little bit what kind of worries me is
that you said whatever you cooked was
alive before you cooked it
yeah is this your first kill in in the
kitchen it's my first kill's devil
in or out of the kitchen joey's starting
his kda right now in order to take off
the kill the fast
we cut here yeah thank you okay so what
would you hear the click like that okay
oh
good sound
nice nice okay oh and then cut out for
the top as well
what was that noise
she's crying oh no no no
don't say that in the meantime our
second guest judge had just arrived so
we got another one of the judges today
and also our manager and boss to judge
our cooking it's mainly
so we should probably explain why we
asked you to be one of the judges today
because you're like
one of the top five top five you're in
the top five percent of google reviewers
in japan but like i've never met anyone
as like dedicated to the google food
reviews as you yeah because because
melin plays google reviews like people
play pokemon go because they have
badges
this is pretty intense i you know i i
knew i was going to kill a fish but
this is definitely uh
more graphic than i had anticipated
after that you have to cut
yeah it's the prettiest sight in the
world is it it's pretty it's
pretty
bloody hell there's a lot of blood oh
shall we move to the sink oh yeah i
guess we should
oh should i leave the knife
oh is this a brush specifically for
cleaning wow
and here's a
another
cut here
oh this
dish
there is a plenty of scale yeah yeah
because we haven't take off the scale
see that yours is much cleaner than mine
here
is that a problem no problem no problem
all right i'll take it what goes into
a good restaurant experience to you the
air conditioning
that is not the first thing people think
of when it's hot in a restaurant i
immediately walk out that's lit
chef koji was making the preparation
look so easy for me however though uh it
yeah definitely wasn't
oh
okay oh no and then just like this
and then just yes
yes looks so much better than mine i
know obviously i'm not very good but
like mine is so messy like it's all i've
messed up all the skin everything is
perfect on yours do you know
how long i have been
i know i know i know i know but i'm just
i'm just saying it's amazing
we have to take
trying his best to follow chef koji we
were trying our best to follow whatever
the hell melin was trying to tell us
have you ever licked sweat
i mean not on purpose okay and how did
it taste i know what sweat is mainly i
know but like i know it's salty
i know i'm i'm i'm
i'm really afraid to ask
but
when have you licked sweat
you don't look safe
please don't tell me you butchered your
husband not on purpose
so before cooking uh we should
salt we have to uh salt it
with proper amount you hold yeah salt
like this okay and then push
shake okay and open a little
be between between the hand
between the finger
that's so beautiful if we do that under
even
yes even and also on their black
uh blackboard
you can see how much you're salting yeah
it's so pretty it's like christmas in
the kitchen
yeah yeah oh okay yeah i see
i can feel like the salt yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah coming from here i
think i'm right out of the salt
you should grab more yeah i'll grab some
more i'm glad everyone can see that
maylene is like a different breed of
human a lot of the time she says some
[ __ ] where i'm just like have you also
ever gotten a fight with your sibling
and you try to like spit on each other's
face or something
or like try to get your drool on their
face like yeah like like you know is
that what you do
we should do the preparation for deep
frying if we uh put it into the uh you
know the deep fried oil so it's gonna be
dangerous yeah yeah yeah because of that
there's a lot of liquid so
very light
oh you're very lightly frying it
whoa
how do we know when it's done
this moment is the white yeah but if you
keep on doing it turns into the brown oh
i see it it's already starting to brown
a little bit and then
i'm just going to cook the filler
so if i feel no pressure
in the middle
yeah no pressure it just goes right in
yeah you know what i'm going to do
during our cooking special melon don't
don't sweat please don't sweat i'm going
to finish my cooking then go for like a
five minute run and be like
okay
there it is
okay yeah
that's really good that's amazing oh my
god can you imagine this is your scale
it's so nice it adds the texture so good
the skin is so nice oh my gosh i guess
i'll try mine now
is it gonna maybe there's too much
texture yeah who knows let's go to shop
hmm
it's good though
yours are definitely better this is
amazing this was so fun even though
yours looks very different to mine this
is really nice thank you so much
thank you thank you the other two judges
are actual chefs so i'm really curious
how they'll judge it they've gone
through the training
they're not like the five percent of
google reviews though let's let's be
honest they wish they were as high of a
like a hierarchy as may lean is right
now in the future i mean let's be honest
what's more important having a michelin
star or having a badge that says you're
a level five dude
finally it was my turn and as nervous as
it was at least it got me away from me
lynn what we are cooking is completely
randomized so it's just uh chopped by
chance that i'm cooking thai messy today
even if i don't end up winning this or
doing a good job i feel like i learnt a
lot of really important skills stop
being wholesome joe you gotta get a
[ __ ] trash talk all right i don't
[ __ ] care about what you love it's
about who wins it's always been about
who wins i mean it doesn't really matter
because i mean this is a trash day
special you're obviously gonna lose once
again
is that the fish yes oh my god this is
sabrina this is sea dream so from now on
um
we are we are going to take off the the
scale the scales and also the internal
and then we grill it
then we make it into their sibling meal
right i'm guessing this is already dead
thankfully i feel like ghana is really
bad at learning things fast it takes
them a while to like absorb yeah
needs to go home watch 10 youtube
tutorials before he feels confident
doing anything you know i might [ __ ] it
up but let's just [ __ ] go for it no
i've never this is the first time i've
prepared fish fresh like this oh okay so
that's completely
that's oh that's that's so smooth i
thought it was still alive back then
just slipping out of my hands this is
like a needle if i don't want to get my
hand anywhere near that so what makes
the best fish what weather yeah weather
and also good relationship with the
refrigerator we are going to wash again
okay
that right is that not cut do i need to
cut there
okay a little more
okay like that and
cut
this is not going as smoothly
you can take it off with my hand you can
take it off my hand
but better to cut yeah
about to go full ape mode there and just
like rip it off okay
yeah like that this is a visual side
right when we
put it on the part right so
this is the
bottom part okay we cut here
how sharp are these knives by the way
ah this is from look at that i feel like
i'm holding a mini samurai sword right
now this isn't a knife this is a hatori
hanzo samurai sword
take off all the internal does it come
off smoothly normally the top edge of
the knife
sweets
it's not coming out smoothly oh no oh no
using your finger right you have to
take off
all of
the internals you don't know
me and joey however weren't feeling too
confident about our dishes so i feel the
three common steps that we have to go
through or rip and tack that too but
also just like it's the process of
filleting a fish like i saw that video
of gordon ramsay doing it with a salmon
and he does it like five [ __ ] seconds
and he's like and there you go that's
how you fill out your fish i literally
couldn't see what you're doing pick up
your knife twist the knife almost as if
it's horizontally underneath the salmon
and you slice
the salmon underneath and let the knife
do the work so let the knife do the work
let the knife do the work and then
suddenly it's in four amazingly cut
pieces i'm sorry gordon my knife is not
sentient like yours it doesn't have a
mind of itself i was thinking like yeah
i'll let the knife do the work when i
was cutting it i had to like really
barbarian like shove that [ __ ] i really
had to tell that knife it was born as
for my dish i was having to go medieval
on this fish's ass i would like to
uh
uh
stab yeah i feel like vlad the impaler
right now oh my god this is like
medieval
uh where's the next one guy
that one oh my god shall we yes let's
grill finally get set things on fire we
have to uh grill this fish or gently not
not so strong
or
power yeah so slow cook yes because it
loses
most of moisture so after we
we put it into the rice and make it uh
make it complete yeah we have to take
off the ball on the skin right then mix
the uh
the meat of fish and rice together i
prefer to have uh more moisture oh okay
okay yes
it gets dried yeah
you know the tasting it tastes easy and
not so good so it takes
maybe 20 minutes to go 20 minutes i
guess we're gonna cut here and you'll
see what the fish looks like when it's
cooked
all right and i guess we're about to
turn them over now okay
ah let's see
is that that's not white yeah so maybe
switch the body piece was positioned
okay
okay and then we'll cut back to when
both fishes are cooked nearly nearly
it can't be completed okay
we
put the rice into the pot into the pot
okay okay this should be the easiest
part for me yeah cooked for ice many
times before three three three cups of
rice okay
okay oh look at that look at that the
eyes look like they've got cataracts in
it right now that's how you can tell i
was cooked and we just take out the
needle okay oh these are looking like
some good grilled fish right now just
one just one just one into
oh we could we cooked the fish with the
rice yes so far my steps seemed pretty
simple there was no way i could [ __ ]
this up right
oh no
no it's okay we got two
fish
what have i done
what have i done don't [ __ ] up god yeah
just be good this was such a big [ __ ]
even chef koji was impressed so the chef
just told me that throughout his entire
year of teaching people how to cook
taimeshi i'm the first person that that
has happened to i am the first person
who's just beheaded a fish in front of
him so i'm very sorry chef i was so
lucky to see you that happened
in his entire life you'll never see
someone [ __ ] up as much as i did when
you cook rice how much water normally to
rice
it depends on their rights and also it
depends on their on the
shield yeah yeah the other normally uh
side by four three by four three by four
yeah yeah okay
my mom teach me when cooked rice you put
the rice in put the water and the water
should be about here above the right is
that same for japan as well in japan we
put the hand right there the water
universally if you're asian everyone for
some reason has been taught to cook rice
the same way in japan it's this much in
thailand stick the finger in first
knuckle you're asian you get it
technically i've broken things
especially and broke the fishes will to
live this is the one special where
you're allowed to break something i'm
going to leave bones and mailings just
despite her
i don't care if million gives me bad
points
it's a sign of boiling okay
can you see yeah so the rice is boiling
yeah and then we have to squeeze
our rice a real okay beef
lift
headless fish yes
a little
okay squeeze
the rice beneath okay the thai otherwise
this part is going to be very stiff
right right we put hachimaki
here
wait a minute wait 10 minutes okay easy
i don't know why the guys are
complaining this is easy i don't know
it's been easy so far still somehow
found a way to [ __ ] it up but uh see you
in 10 minutes
when we both filleted the fish
i immediately was like i know which one
is mine
even when he was deboning it somehow he
took the bones out without ripping the
skin like you just like massaged them
out like a pimple it's like what the
[ __ ] whereas when i pull my bone
[ __ ] ripping it all apart why am i
what the [ __ ] going on yeah before
turning off their
fire
oh we go
full power yes three
oh three second three
what does that do yeah so in in japan we
think uh this uh
last three minutes quite a strong fire
moisture away oh moisture put all the
moisture away okay okay just wanna just
wanna
talk about this stand right now this is
a very fancy looking stand
all right boys you ready for the money
shots
wow look at that
oh that smells really good something was
beginning to worry me this dish had
already taken twice the amount of time
as the other boys and now chef koji was
delicately taking his time deboning this
fish with chopsticks so now we have to
take off all the bones in the skin i'm
guessing it's going to be the hardest
part of the cook right the meat or the
cheek is really delicious so we put the
meat there
okay
i'm gonna have to remember this exact
order oh my god okay i'm paying close
attention
just take off the skin okay just take
off the skin so you must be very good
with chopsticks to be able to do this
with chopsticks i'm getting pretty
worried now because it seems like a very
delicate thing to do and
this is way more than we do in thailand
in thailand if there's a bone in the
fish we're just like all right whatever
it's already in the fish we'll find the
bone when we start chewing on the food
i mean he's making this look easy i
don't think it's going to be that easy
can you make things their fish and rest
together
just keep on watching uh
for burns
let's have a size
hmm
this is perfect as a thai person i'm
used to putting so many sauces and so
many spices with my dish but what i love
about japanese food is that the
ingredients are so good
now you don't need to do much to it oh
my god that fish is amazing that's all
the dish i suppose i'm gonna hope i can
recreate it as good on on the shokugeku
which i guess we're gonna be doing next
so see you guys then finally after
waiting a millennia for god to finish
his dish it was time to cook so we've
all just finished our cooking lessons
and we're about to start the shokugeki
the food war is about to begin i'm gonna
make everyone naked sorry to interrupt
you joey i just wanted to put that out
there so all three of us will be cooking
our own dishes all at the same time in
like a battle royale type of thing uh we
have a one-hour time limit and rip me
yeah
i'm gonna still be here while these guys
are getting served serving food to the
judges how are you boys feeling ready
ready for my dad you know ready as i'll
ever be i guess i'm trying to like
memorize all the steps which it's not
too many for me so i'm wondering how you
boys are feeling i'm gonna just you know
like a monk right i'm gonna i'm gonna
feel it out when i get there i've
forgotten everything i'm just gonna go
into zen mode and just feel what the
fish wants me to do i can see why you
need zen training as a japanese chef
here but you need that concentration and
i'll say i'll have the advantage may the
best win and best i mean me because i'm
on a one win streak right now let's get
let's keep it too you know what i'm
saying let's get to may the best chef
win
monkey chef karen let's do it
quit your bitchin because i'm coming to
the kitchen baby
kill me these boys think they know how
now i'm gonna show them a real kitchen
nightmare i'm here to serve up the
competition these were the steps that
chef koji had taught the three of us to
follow with a time limit of one hour to
follow everything we were taught what
could possibly go wrong all right
gentlemen be gentleman be civilized you
don't have to rush in the start we'll
get our fish joy joe joe what you got
there what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
that you guys call that a knife that's a
knife classic lolly lover over
compensating
three
two
one
all right well i'm pretty easy i'm right
over here it's pretty easy too
oh my god it's slippery mine is not easy
so excuse me so i am the first to the
sink and how do i have the descaler the
cook-off had started but i don't think
the boys were prepared to see my first
challenge
what the [ __ ] is that mine's alive all
right we're about to witness [ __ ]
murder here in trash taste some of you
may find the following scene disturbing
so we've taken the liberty of censoring
it for use to make sure that youtube
doesn't destroy our channel however you
can check out our patreon if you'd like
to witness this massacre caught in 4k
what's going on
what
oh jesus christ what off
oh joey stop
joey it's bloodies everything
all right got it joey it's already dead
while joey was busy recreating a scene
from game of thrones i'd already
forgotten my first steps oh this is real
tough oh no
what have i done
i'm having a chill time over here
um i'm just trying to uh i just hope
joey has killed his fish
ethnically i think my guys did
i like to think my guy is dead hopefully
and hopefully i mean i mean half his
head is hanging off so uh i feel like i
just witnessed attack on titan in real
life here yeah i think i think he's dead
i think he's dead can you can you check
if he's dead
dude i'm not good look at these eyes i
think i definitely cut the wrong area
all right let me just wipe that down i
gotta pull it out first haven't i oh i'm
doing all the things in the wrong holder
it's a lot of blood there joe no i know
i'm gonna get rid of it oh my god
joey joey as you can see cleaning up the
murder scene yeah
i mean i'm not quite done yet actually
okay
all right there goes the head
and now i believe i have to use this
like euthanasia i've already started
forgetting my steps i all right i think
that is a mostly descaled fish oh that
that's no no that's definitely not
correct uh is it here is it here nope
it's here
oh it's definitely there okay sure where
the [ __ ] are you having frankenstein's
experiments over there i'm trying to
euthanize it hold on tell me is it
locked
why is that moving why is that moving
hold on i'm euthanizing it give me a
second all right and rest in peace all
right got it [ __ ] just reanimating
the dead here it's all right this is
good this thing is going to be delicious
mark my words better be i think i've
done a few errors here boys but should
be fine conor wasn't the only one though
as it seems like everything we were
shown had completely gone out the window
yeah i've definitely done an error this
uh it's not supposed to be this bloody
something i have to pull out here i
remember
how do i get out of the gills again i
completely forgot do i just [ __ ] rip
them out i actually cannot remember
the
uh
i've definitely done this wrong chef
koji had taken the time to show us how
to make the cleanest cuts but our fish
was the furthest thing from that [ __ ]
crime scene
uh boys this is very uh not right as i
remember jack the ripper is like crying
right now look at that i'm getting in
touch with my local hero jack the ripper
and i'm remembering what he talked did i
just cut the gun oh that's leaking
that's leaking
that's oh
oh my god
the gut juice wait i don't think this is
what i was supposed to do i did not i
don't think this is what i was supposed
to do wait was i meant to cut the guts
out or was i just meant to rip it out
okay
yeah boys i don't know how you're
feeling but i feel like this is not what
i'm meant to be doing no
definitely not how are you guys not
freaking out huh how are you guys not
freaking out i'm kind of just like half
giving up not gonna lie this is so
difficult now i genuinely forgot how i
[ __ ] this up so much hold on i gotta
clean this out more i feel like i got a
bit of stomach juice on my fish and i
don't know
if that was salvageable because i
completely burst the intestines this top
layer should not be here actually it
should just come
cut off but
okay hold on i'm going to try and get my
knife in there
oh no i'm missing out a lot of the meat
hold on hold on hold on
tomate please
bones galore
it's fine it's fine
victor looks so concerned he's like what
the [ __ ] is connor doing over there
good fish that that's a good fish you
know how it slaps back what did you say
connor it slaps back i'll tell you now
it's a good fish this is not what i did
before this is definitely not what i did
before um what did i do before [ __ ]
start stabbing the [ __ ] out of this fish
it's so slimy
got it
there's so much meat left over [ __ ] my
life dude god's like [ __ ] doing a
henry viii over here on his fish like
the [ __ ] are you doing they're gone mate
why are you impaling that [ __ ] i gotta
impale it okay it needs to be impaled in
times of stress i had only one thing i
could turn to making fate references no
to my fellow fate fans you know you know
shut the [ __ ] up you know that scene in
fate apocrypha where vlad just uses
notable phantasm this is it this is what
i'm doing right now you guys know what i
mean right yeah yeah man yeah man i feel
like i've missed five crucial steps but
we're still carrying on anyway hold on
hold on
this might be a success hold on hold on
hold on boys hold on this is looking
good this is looking good it's looking
good gill's gone blood sack gone
intestines gone is it supposed to come
in parts like that you know what i'm
gonna wash it again just in case i'm
gonna wash it again
a fish can never be too clean right
fish can never be too
clean going to be a scale when you're
done with it
look all i'm saying is the fishes live
in water so therefore they can never be
too clean i swear when i was like
practicing with the chef this thing
could you know
cut these they could sense its presence
it could you could cut the air with this
and then suddenly it's in my hands and
it's turned into a metal stick like i
can't get through this [ __ ] fish just
listen to gordon ramsay's letting life
do the work you know just just let the
knife through the knife do the work
knife do the work um
where the [ __ ] is the kitchen foil i
tried to do like a clean cut this is the
cleanest i could get and uh oh my god
look at yours that one's fine that one
that one's a fine one this is the fine
one look at my one
what is that bad or good it's [ __ ]
where's the me
that's the me supposedly there's no meat
there cherry me okay um
[ __ ] how high is this
flame meant to be
um
um
it was halfway halfway and now
i wait around 10 minutes i think it
seemed like gand had a bit of free time
on his hands a bit too much because he
started talking [ __ ] about my amazing
cooking don't think i supposed to waste
this much what's the worst
that's wasted me that's the spine though
you want it no well then [ __ ] off then
shut up
you know this is like good ingredients
right now this this is i know this is
good ingredients gone that's why i'm
[ __ ] it up
oh [ __ ] my life that should have come
off earlier oh no no
okay
um i hope my fish is being built alright
i think it's this part here that i'm
supposed to cut off yes so i'm gonna do
that surely i can't [ __ ] up just a
simple grilled fish right surely i'll be
pretty embarrassed if i did keep it
clean
it's not clean
nothing about this nothing about this i
can see the slight stain of blood yeah
nothing about this is clean how much how
much how much meat have you wasted not
much at all why
absolutely nothing looks like a very
anorexic fish shut the [ __ ] up god shut
the [ __ ] up
i'm fighting for my life just to get
these bones out bro why is this fish two
different colors this came from the same
fish that's not right cook
it's so nice that doesn't
i've never been so stressed watching
fire in my life normally i love watching
fire fire's great but now i'm
i'm seeing that the fire is not cooking
this way why is god so damn loud god i'm
trying to focus
finally though it seems like i had found
some order in the chaos what are you
doing what are you doing connor
having everything go well for me god
that's exactly what i'm doing i'm just
preparing the fish a little bit is the
uh meat meant to be that uh check this
[ __ ] out boys check this [ __ ] out check
this [ __ ] out
i am skinning this like a [ __ ]
right now look at that are you letting
the knife do the work i'm wetting the
knife to the work baby
okay that was clean look at that that's
clean
that's a clean skin right there i was
still also making an absolute mess of
things but god also had his own problems
to worry about
[Music]
okay okay
so while that fish is waiting let me
prepare the rice and cut this part off
okay now it looks like the same fish
i've managed to salvage this
all right um how many cups of rice three
cups of rice
oh god gets a [ __ ] easy job he just
has to make rice like i put it in the
rice cooker yeah put in the rice cooker
so much skill i know right look look at
you guys talking a lot of [ __ ] for
someone who just made rice and skewer
the fish hey making rice is a hard job
i'm sorry did you take a life today just
just ask did you take a life today no
joe did you steal a life from an
innocent animal today murder isn't on my
hands joey there is no blood in my hands
i'm sorry well there is blood on my
hands i'm gonna go wash it off
how long does it take to cook rice
what what this is going to mean is i'm
going to have to speed run
the bone taking out process
i don't feel like my time is being
optimally utilized here meanwhile the
judges were cautiously optimistic about
what we were cooking up what's been your
tactic mailing have you
are you going into this tasting hungry
in order to get more excited about the
food or have you already eaten because
you are so confident that what we're
about to try is inedible well at first i
was gonna go into this like
hungry but i think because we were
running behind schedule i was getting so
hungry i had a sandwich
yeah
but i only had like two bites of that
sandwich okay i don't know how about you
guys
well i don't know originally i just
thought well this is going to be you
know my meal but then i was hearing such
negative conversation i had nothing to
worry about though because i was doing a
great job
[Applause]
my bad that's that's why i'm nervous
that's why i'm so nervous right on cue
almost as if we
i can assure viewers out there that was
not planned at all
i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm good what
is this man doing what is this clown
doing in here i think someone cut
themselves
i'm good don't worry about it there's no
extra human flavor in it right bro he's
trying to get that human blood taste to
it how is it teaching the three of them
they haven't got any experience on
cooking so i was so anxious about it but
you know
after i tried it so i found this so nice
guy they listen to my explanation and
try to understand
i know and also they
have learned from
a lot of cooking
things are from the youtube right
youtube you do i think uh they will
manage oh that's a lot of meat that's
coming off this fish um you know i don't
have time to worry about that who was
the best in the kitchen i guess when it
came to handling the tools three of them
are the completed same level not one is
better than the other that's interesting
oh [ __ ]
i think
[ __ ] that's a lot of you know what the
me can go into me that's a lot of damage
you're right they're gone no i'm not all
right oh i love that dish that you're
making
i actually really like that i've had
that before yeah yeah time machine yeah
it's really fun yeah time issue is
really good that's a [ __ ] one as well
two and a half
okay
um
not stopping at breaking the kitchen god
was also trying to hog the grill and now
i just [ __ ] cook this
all right now that we're basically done
just gotta fire
oh god i need to use that as well how
long is that gonna take uh a long time
are you serious
what the [ __ ] there's another one there
there's another one there you can't use
that one i think i have to use that one
it's tied do you have to use this one
yeah because i'm using the deep fat
fryer oil so there's no way you can go
on that with the cage uh we're gonna
have to take the cage off hold on i
don't need to use the cajun this feels
like an oversight we should have had two
stoves well that sounds like your guys's
[ __ ] problem why is there bricks next
to it that's not good uh that's for the
grill okay
how do i turn it on how do you ignite it
oh all the way
what are you making tempura
tempura you're deep frying it yeah deep
you don't deep fry tempura
what do you want about me that nicely
[ __ ] it up get it all nice and battered
i think my rice is still going to be
cooking by the time the time when it's
over it's good for you annette should
have thought about that yeah sounds like
your problem mate while the boys were
still stressing out over who was going
to get the grill i was already putting
on my finishing touches to the dish i'm
almost done seriously you're almost done
all right where is the
[Music]
excuse me
out of the way i don't know what you're
in a rush for joe you're almost done
he's got he's got no worries in the
world yeah
i gotta add my own spin to it right
yeah
what's that
by [ __ ] all over i'm gonna have
about five minutes to de-bone this fish
that does sound like you probably gone
what are they doing
i just hear noise and things dropping on
the ground yeah there's some dropping
there's been some abuse of each other as
well aggressive words agree some
aggressive words some flappy
flowery language let's see what comes
out though 20 minutes to go very
exciting look at look at that nice sweat
look at that
that's that's something
that's some nice seasoning for melinda
that's disgusting he's vile god's vile
yeah there's good stuff i'm doing a
little improv right here
because i'm gonna put some twisty double
horns on it's good so i'm gonna be
frying this
make a really nice effect on when we
find i'll show you we'd give you a
little master class of swords
welcome to connor's kitchen lads
step one don't burn down the house
good advice
all right dick stop oh wow he's done all
right go and take it over joe oh joe
what's that what's that joey what's that
just
oh
what the [ __ ]
it's japanese
oh my god you wanna watch this
grab it let's show first time
easy
put that there for now and then we're
gonna hope this where the [ __ ] do i put
this this was it i'd finish my dish and
it was finally time to show the judges
to say i was nervous
is a bit of an understatement
the devil's flounder
so the motif uh for this dish is that i
have used the twisty carrots as little
devil horns little radish devil in the
middle you seem so nervous i'm sweating
my ass off right now wait doesn't that
mean there's extra flavor there is extra
flavor
why am i so nervous
i never imagined that you're going to
use these twisted carrot
just like other as a horn this is the
first time is ever having anything i
prepared
oh it's boiling everywhere so why don't
you just put it in straight away i don't
know that's what the chef did okay
that's what he told me to do is that
boiling that's almost bubbling what are
the odds of a grease fire
um please don't say anything on fire
connor i'm trying my hardest minute i'm
trying my hardest over here this is
really hot now this is really
old
oh i know melanie's that's a good art
maybe it's a bit thick it's a bit much
to chew
but
it's actually good because i like
chewing on things i feel like the more i
chew something it
slowly releases other flavors in my
mouth i like chewing on things so it's
it's good but
wow that's a somewhat positive review
from maylene oh joey was impressing i
still had to find a way past my biggest
obstacle the laws of physics all right
now i gotta wait ten minutes uh for this
rice to cook maybe if i turn up the heat
a little bit just a little how much more
have you burned up the heat gun well the
finesse in my dish is just gone because
i don't have time to finesse this dish
i've never been more nervous in my life
you are amazing
[Music]
never expected you you can
do this i think by the time
i take this dish off connor's already
gonna be finished this looks beautiful
gentlemen i've got to say this just
looks fantastic let's see what all this
fuss is about honestly the acceptance
from koji is feels better than any
acceptance i've ever had from my parents
i'm just saying that right now no
offense parents
oh my that was a very japanese tv of you
i'm auditioning for a role fuji
television if you're watching in terms
of what corgis taught you i think you've
done a pretty good job i mean practice
makes perfect the things you would have
to work on over time i think is cutting
that fish you know with the grain mainly
you commented on the chewiness you need
the balance between you know being
making it chewy but also making it light
that takes years to master i i mean to
be honest i'm disappointed you didn't
master it in the hour that you've been
given jesus high expectations but uh
pretty good job oh [ __ ] i forgot a step
i just remembered he put he put the
towel over it to make it go faster
um that chopsticks just make sure
everything's everything's prepared for
my speed run this deboning that we're
about to do
[Music]
i gotta wait another five minutes i just
oh god i'm not gonna make him time i
already know i'm not gonna make any time
i'm going to give this 8 out of 10.
okay joey i think you've done a
fantastic job really love the
presentation for me to score you higher
i would have
liked to have seen a little bit more
care taken on the cutting of the fish
but other than that it's a fantastic job
given it's your first time making
flounder sashimi which is a very hard
type of sashimi to make so
congratulations thank you
all right maylene i promise i won't hate
you no matter what score you give me i
hope they take their time so conor can
present his dish and while they're while
they're judging connor's dish
i can still finish my dish
oh guys take your time no worries about
it something that's kind of was a little
off-putting for me despite it being very
delicious and very cute from afar where
there are
some
remnants of scales if i were to order
this at a restaurant and then i see a
scale or i happen to get a piece of the
scale on the fish and then i feel it my
mouth i would kind of be like oh that's
a little fishy because i know scales
are kind of fishy and they just ruin the
flavor right away i happened to actually
grab a piece that didn't have the scales
so the only issue was yeah the thickness
and probably the way it looks on the
plate
it's
kind of what do you call not cleanly cut
but it tasted really great
gosh what should i give it i'm not gonna
say anything just just what do you think
uh
seven
seven we take those we take those we put
it on there
[Music]
time to [ __ ]
speed run deboning this jesus christ
this man's got a donkey kong crate for
his food on this three speaking no i'll
just to give you
points 10
10 i want oh you want i want i was gonna
say jesus christ because this is your
first time so
probably one of the most difficult parts
not making sashimi is take off the skin
yeah so
how did you do that it's funny because
the skin taking part was the only part i
did perfectly like i don't know what i
think i'm really good at taking off the
skin because that was the only part
where i just went and it was perfect
yeah i don't know how i did it either
but i did it
i give it
hell yeah because of course that
thing is
sashimi is really good
i i found this thickness was really good
maybe i should try this thickness
because the chewing is really really
good and also you know from the point of
view of shame
so
the big concern about this sashimi was
take off the skin right so
he managed it after i finally managed to
get god off of the grill and complete my
dish it was time for my judging and to
say that i was not confident would be a
lie because i was extremely confident
that i would win i don't want to think
about this before i go and set it off
this is great con that's great fantastic
that's what i love to hear thank you
guys oh my god dude i'm so [ __ ] proud
of myself for that they [ __ ] clapping
they're clapping oh they'd be cheering
when i come out i just managed to get a
25 out of 30. so let's see oh i think
connor's ready so
let's let's move on to connor's dish
yeah we got 25 out of 30 points
[ __ ] man
bon appetit gentlemen
it's gonna be nice all right here's my
dish i don't know how good it is we'll
find out
why is it so scary actually because it
looks it looks like teeth i'm looking
forward to trying this one it's amazing
let's rewind back a bit because while
conor was being judged i had to de-bone
my fish and make it presentable it took
a michelin star chef about 15 minutes to
do what i had to do
in three minutes how am i gonna de-burn
this i've got to figure out a way to
de-bone this as quickly as possible all
right
itadakimasu
smells good yes all right
this is coming i wasn't nervous but i'm
nervous i want to hate it but it's good
yeah this is who really likes it five
four
three
two
one
time
i've completely ruined this dish
i'm done i'm done i've gone out of time
this tile fish
i'm a dye it's another fish that can be
tough to work with when you're creating
this kind of a fried
version of it it can be tough to get the
balance between you know the delicious
oiliness the reason why we love fried
food but then not you know overly uh
overly do it but
i'm very impressed i will say
surprisingly impressed yes
i got a 10 from the sensei himself so
yeah
win or lose
i feel good i'm more confident in the
kitchen now for sure this is a complete
disaster i'm sorry chef i'm so sorry i
think the taste was great
very heavy though kind of definitely on
the oily side but probably because it's
very difficult to get the balance me
personally i
have like a phobia of scales i've been
shut up
the last moment when i close my eyes
just don't think about the scales the
textures were just amazing the piece
that i got had a lot of scales but that
felt very nice the texture is very great
just the bottom bit was a little
undercooked but the top
if you focus on the crunch you kind of
forget that it's kind of still soft at
the bottom the flavor amazing oil a
little oily presentation was awful it
was just like he fried things and threw
it on there so i felt like there's no
care at all i'm trying to pick the parts
of the rice that don't have bones and uh
and their skin in there because i know
that's
that's bad actually just mary said or
it's a little bit
oily
this a deep-fried dish
fish uh is going to
make
oil a little bit
worse
quickly
because
it has come it contained a lot of
water the water is going to
make
oil
worse right okay so don't be careful
okay
if you want to up visual points that red
tray looks okay i'll i'll up the visual
points what about those all-important
scores let's start with corju-sam
how are you going to rate this i
would like to
okay i'll take it that's good that's
great i mean i'm happy with that
this is the only reason why i deserve
that i deserve that thank you okay
before connor goes into a deep bow of
apology for his bone uh melin i would
say taste was a ten the feeling it left
me before i didn't like the way the oil
felt
presentation was quite terrible but the
taste was so like there who's the
harshest in rules in terms of judging me
but gosh ah what do i want to give it be
honest melon six seven six can we do a
decimal place no no round up round out
round down round up or down i don't know
i just you did you didn't put enough
thought into the plating there's not
much i can do really it's just four
pieces of fish he's giving you attitude
okay six
seven
seven
just give it a six six
seven it's a seven it's a shot i'm more
looking forward to presenting my dish i
also agree it was a little bit oily but
hearing chef corgi's explanation that
you reused the same oil from before
that's put you at a disadvantage so i
can't mark you down for that instead i
can judge you based on the ingredients
you had to work with i think you've done
a fantastic job so actually i'm going to
give you eight
out of ten okay thank you very much i
think that what does that put me out 23.
finally my time had come i just had to
hope that my disaster was successfully
covered up it's just rice it's time
issue oh
all right i was mostly watching these
guys cook and i had very little time to
prepare the dish in the time given i
hope i didn't miss any bones all right
itadakimasu
this is uh way more nerve-wracking than
i thought it was going to be got a layer
of oil on my face that i can't get off i
just took a bite of connor's thing and
like my lips are [ __ ] oily [ __ ] now
are we allowed to comment
no oh my god that's not a good sign
i'm getting the strange texture
melon you think the rice is undercooked
well it's not the texture i like but
the flavors are really good she's gonna
be nice she likes gone i want to leave
right now
god's a favorite child culture sam well
while malin's composing herself
for the judgement of paris here what uh
what do you think
they amaze me again
you try to pick up
the phone as much as you can i can feel
your you know
courage oh my god my heart is beating so
fast now
every single dish is so amazing
so that's why my judgment is always too
positive you know it's a good job we've
got good cop here bad cop in the middle
really it's so harsh for me gun
it was tough for you because this is
actually one of my favorite things to
eat ever you know i've eaten this many
times at corgi's former restaurant
yotaro and now in his current home
hinokichow i will travel a long way for
this incredible dish this thai meshi and
i think shit's hit [ __ ] i think you've
done a pretty good job thank you very
much i'm very proud of yourself
i'm wondering if some of that texture
that melin isn't liking is just that the
rice is a little little bit too
al dente maybe
basically after after boiling the the
soup stock we have to
turn the light down uh wait for 10
minutes yeah after that
we turn off the
the fire yeah and then we have to wait
another 10 minutes yeah so this either
you know the basic rule but uh he hasn't
got the time
so that's why mary you're right so this
is not a little bit stiff
but because of that process he cannot
manage it so if he had maybe 10 more
minutes maybe yes but millions well i'm
hearing that i have to give a 10. yeah
it's like [ __ ] off and you [ __ ] love
it before melon says her judgment i'm
just saying i'm i'm like
so pleased with the wonderful feedback
from
the two chefs right now um i'm i can't
really describe this feeling right now i
just hope ganda's worse than me it's not
fair that i lost i was i did the best
this is like when my parents praised me
almost i know exactly how joey feels now
he went over time so you should be
penalized for that i was looking at
koji and max bowl and they i guess all
the grains of rice were put in the
middle nicely mine were just like it's
you like you took the paddle or
something was like and you were like
this
so i i felt like you were in a rush in a
lunch kitchen or something hurry hurry
up and serve the food
[Music]
flavor was really good there was one
bone presentation was not good you say
if you like the fish and it was
undercooked
hmm
sorry
it's a six
that was a six
that was the six i'm happy i'll take the
six uh don't you mean a four at least
that was a four expression maybe what
you want about the flavors were really
good i'm i'm sure it would have been
fixed if you cooked it just a little
more do everything perfect she just
doesn't like the food because that's her
toast i get a six seven sorry god is my
favorite child after all you you never
have you never stood a chance i was
expecting a lot worse i'll take a six
you're kidding me this is so biased what
the [ __ ]
the the difference in criticism to the
score is shocking what i can't believe
this this is so stupid you got a six too
literally bailey's criticism like it's
not cooked it looks [ __ ] everything's
awful sick same as connors what
kind of just being salty again as usual
unlike maelyn i don't poo poo everything
the minute i eat it normally takes a few
hours so for me you are doing well
you're almost on track for a nine until
that last mouthful that i took because i
was loving it so much had a fairly
sizable bone in it
i'm gonna have to give you in line with
the other guys and score you an eight
which uh you should be pretty proud of
thank you very much you're too kind
watch yourself
if you give them a 10 i'm going to
scream the texture is
really good you told me your mother
told you or you know
of course
i can't believe he's playing with his
emotions to get points
thank you mom oh my god mom you saved me
today so i i would like to give you 10.
but
i found the phone so
i'm going to give you 9. thank you very
much arigatou gozaimasu
let's go
congratulations anyway great you know
what considering what i thought i would
get once i walked up here i will take
the 23. hey it's all right guys you you
tied with connor yeah absolute joke come
here come here come on come on i don't
want to see you my fellow man how much
you pay me lean huh how much you pay me
lead huh [ __ ] up well guys
looks like
i came out on top today the guy with the
least amount of experience behind the
kitchen
is the winner let's go i've uh i've come
up with a few excuses first of all i
think the fact that you went get went
first you get all the tens all the nines
and then they they're like i gotta scale
it back you know you guys should have
probably hurried up then i'm sorry i
can't like change the laws of physics
joey hey at least i didn't come with a
[ __ ] like my mum taught me cooking
soft stuff yeah well you said what's
this [ __ ] sob story pulling out at
the end what is this [ __ ] look i'm just
happy i didn't come last i should have
told that story actually how i saved
that orphan who had cancer with this
fish i
you know how reality tv works but you
obviously should have done this before
it was 23 25 23. yeah how i mean
listening to both of the critics that
meline gave there was a stark difference
and absolutely like this sounded like a
seven and this sounded like a tube and
what millions only excuse that she had
that she didn't like it he made a good
reason as to why so then what's up with
that i got cucked see what i said right
from the start look i don't like the
rules of the game i just play it connor
can continue being salty as he always is
but you know what can i say look it
doesn't matter i came out on top i got
the w
that's all that matters
[Music]
okay
well what's that what is this especially
prepare for the loser but since we have
two
losers for this competition well i'm not
the loser so i'm gonna just hang back
and enjoy the show so i've been made to
suffer again by melee this uh this is an
atrocity i want you to close your eyes
so that you don't see it i'm gonna
figure out what it is
let me guess it's the dangerous puffer
fish that kills you
if this is another bug i'm going to just
leave right now all right i'm going to
i'm going to put it in your hand you got
you got go touch it is it alive no all
right
boys ready yes you're just going to take
one big bite all right let's put it in
your mouth in three two one
[Music]
it's not bad no i like it
it's pretty good what the [ __ ] not bad
fence is like
a bit burnt bit salty i've lived in
japan for long enough to know that
hopefully won't surprise me what it is
okay what is it what is it
tantra
you're kidding me that's tarantula
why does it taste good
i'm so glad i didn't see it
wait what did what did it look like it
looked like the moment he cut it in half
it was just like three hairy legs just
came out
why didn't it taste like a like a spider
should i i don't know i feel like if you
guys actually saw it you would have
shoot yourselves you know what i [ __ ]
with it i [ __ ] with tarantula
what the [ __ ] that's what i just ate
that's what you just said yeah look at
that did you cook it or is it just put
it in he literally just he just put it
in
is this a normal dish no i i've never
tried the what
that could have been awful you know what
that was probably the best forfeit i've
done on trash taste ingredients
tarantula salt
so apparently tarantula just tastes like
burnt
burnt wood but of course we couldn't do
this special thanks to our wonderful
teachers yeah the lovely chefs kojima
mask come on in
thank you so much
honestly they're the real mvps for the
special i guess uh joey is now retired
as a youtuber bye bye anime michelin
star chef here he comes
all right i guess we haven't got
anything else to say i mean back to the
studio i guess back to the studio
well boys i finally got my dog what a
load of [ __ ]
[ __ ] god gone i didn't know
protagonists felt this good oh my god
dude this is you
this is obviously just your japanese
cheating blood just like giving you the
w i've gone from side character to
protagonist just for today
all i will say is i think melin's got
the wrong job working here geeks plus
because she would have an amazing time
working at ign
yeah i think so
you really did pull like a 7.8 out of 10
too much water [ __ ] on you
like i was watching on the sidelines i'm
like oh that's that's hard you know if
you actually check marlene's linkedin
now it'd actually show you that she
worked at a [ __ ] farm because that
was a load of [ __ ] i can't believe that
man i'm actually this it's like two
months later since it happened and i'm
still angry about it the one thing that
i am a little bit sad about is the fact
that even though i did get the dub like
you can't even see half my process no
i'm just i'm just like happy that i
didn't become full last you know because
i just had zero time to work with and
that was probably the most stressful
five minutes of this of my life trying
to de-bone this fish all i'm glad is
that no one actually like cut their
fingers or anything like that like no
blood that wasn't fish blood was spilled
i was gonna say
but no human blood thank god i feel like
we like murdered half of the amazon
rainforest doing this as well like
tarantulas fish like the entire
wildlife's gone i'm telling you i can't
watch finding nemo again you know i i
can't do that man i can't do that
without licking my lips
that that dentist scene could have been
a lot darker
also that tarantula actually didn't
taste that bad maybe because he
presented it too well yeah he like i saw
him preparing it and before he threw it
into the bed of rice i was like oh man
the boys are not going to enjoy this but
then it came out looking like something
i'd pay like 550 before it was pretty
damn delicious you know what this is how
like dogs feel when they get medicine
right i didn't i didn't couldn't even
taste it i didn't you if you didn't ask
me what it was
i don't know what it is
i'll take the big pill i was i was
eating it i was like when when's the
forfeit begin
i was waiting for something like gushing
or something yeah
i was expecting it but i guess i don't
know he did that's the michelin star
show for you he cooked it too good he
did we should have got like someone else
today i should have cooked
yes you should have cooked it joe but
who do you think won and why is it me
and uh why is meline a terrible judge
i'm never gonna let her forget it i i do
like the fact though that uh before we
even conceptualize the this food special
that a lot of people were like man i
really want trash taste to do like a
food special yeah and the entire time we
were editing and filming this we were
like [ __ ] how did they know
i was like i was like going through past
episodes being like did we leave here no
we definitely didn't leave hints i think
he was people just it was inevitable
yeah like with how much we talk about
food we know that you guys would want to
judge our cooking skills now it's on
full display yeah so hopefully you guys
enjoyed it hopefully if we do this again
in future we should all do the same dish
oh yeah yeah that would be you know what
i would like to make my own dish because
i'm [ __ ] trying to follow it's like a
terrible idea that sounds like an
amazing idea so i can prove myself that
i'm a better cook because i didn't have
enough time to cook my dish okay
that was you did get [ __ ] over yeah
the protagonist powers did not favor you
today i lost my technicality it was
literally impossible
to cook my dish in the time that i had
thanks to you again guys hopefully you
enjoyed this special and if you'd like
to support future trash day specials
because there's a lot more where that
came from then make sure to go over to
our patreon patreon.com trash taste and
that was it we'll see you guys next time
bye
[Music]
you